this is the easiest thing you can do to
start getting to know yourself.
and when I did this,
it changed my freaking life.
I want you to ask yourself what your core values are.
write down your top 5:10 core values.
go on Google and search up core values
if you're not too sure what they actually are,
but start to look through them and just get to see, like,
hey, which ones feel right to me?
now, you're probably wondering, like,
why would I ask you to do that?
and it's because these things are gonna be like
cornerstones for the type of person you are.
your values represent who you are at your core.
and once you get clear on this,
then you can start to see,
hey, do my values line up with my schedule and routine?
the work that I do each day,
the relationships that I have in my life?
everything begins to get clearer for you.
and so what I want you to do right now
is get the notes app on your phone,
grab your journal,
whatever it is you gotta do,
write out your top 5 to 10 core values,
and just start to see who you are.
it's a fun exercise,
and I guarantee you
it gives you a lot more clarity in your life
moving forwards.
you got this.